(Mann) Tschannenmatte 18.
Eine Tageskarte. Jawohl, sehr gut.
Vielen Dank, einen schönen Tag.
Auf Wiederhören.
Geschäftsführer Andreas Wiedmer
wäre bereit für die Skisaison.
Aber es fehlt noch der Schnee.
Für Weihnachten und Neujahr
haben wir eigentlich einen Plan B.
Falls es keinen Schnee geben sollte,
wäre das Bergrestaurant in Betrieb.
Oberhalb des Restaurants
gäbe es ein Trampolin ...
... und wir würden
Ponyreiten anbieten.
Wenn Ponyreiten
statt Skifahren im Angebot steht,
Dann ist man wohl in einem Skigebiet
unter 2'000 m Höhe.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
In einem Gebiet, wo sich Menschen
gegen das drohende Ende
des klassischen Wintertourismus
stemmen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
8 °C.
Im Berner Oberländer Diemtigtal
könnte man drei Wochen
vor Weihnachten noch mountainbiken,
aber nicht Ski fahren.
Die Bergbahnen Wiriehorn
durchleben schwierige Zeiten.
Nur dank finanzieller Unterstützung
der Gemeinde und neuer Investoren
konnte man vorletztes Jahr
einen Konkurs verhindern.
Der Winterumsatz
ist stark zurückgegangen.
Jahr für Jahr?
- Ja, Jahr für Jahr.
Und die letzten fünf Jahre
ist es kritisch geworden.
Es gab zwei Winter,
die noch nicht so schlecht waren.
Aber danach gab es zwei Winter,
die katastrophal waren.
An Weihnachten und Neujahr
fuhren wir praktisch nicht.
Wir hatten immer das Gefühl,
es wäre okay.
Wir hatten es
eigentlich gut im Griff.
Doch die letzten drei, vier schlech-
ten Winter brachen uns das Genick.
Andreas Wiedmer ist seit Jahren tech-
nischer Leiter der Wiriehornbahnen.
Wegen eines Abganges
in der Geschäftsleitung
hat er letzten Frühling
auch noch die Finanzen
und das Personal übernommen.
Derzeit dreht sich
fast alles ums Wetter.
Am Samstag Schnee, ja, aber 5 °C.
Jawohl.
- Hier sind Wanderer.
Aber ich bin sehr froh, dass es
geregnet hat und noch warm ist.
Es hätte ja auch sein können,
dass es kalt gewesen wäre
und wir beschneit hätten.
Wenn der Wärmeeinbruch gekommen
wäre, nachdem wir beschneit hätten,
hätten wir zuschauen können,
wie der Schnee bachab geht.
Das Beschneien der Pisten
ist unmöglich.
Im Moment
bleiben ihm nur Wartungsarbeiten.
Wie wichtig ist das Skigebiet, z.B.
die ganze Infrastruktur da hinten?
Ist es auf den Winter ausgerichtet?
Ja, also, in den Gebäuden,
die man hier hinten sieht,
sind überall Ferienwohnungen.
Diese sind eigentlich ziemlich
auf den Winter ausgerichtet.
An Weihnachten und Neujahr sind
sie eigentlich zu 100 % besetzt.
Ja, ziemlich.
- Wie waren denn die Reaktionen?
* Handyklingeln *
- Darf ich kurz rangehen? - Ja.
(Frauenstimme) Seltsam.
Ja, und jetzt?
Wiriehornbahnen, Wiedmer.
Hallo, Rolf.
Wiedmers Telefon klingelt häufig,
er muss sich um alles kümmern.
Noch ist er entspannt.
Wann rechnest du
mit dem ersten Einsatz der Kanonen?
Nächste Woche.
Ich bin zuversichtlich -
sehr.
Laut den Langzeitwetterprognosen
sollte es nächste Woche
einen Kälteeinbruch geben.
Aber Langzeitprognosen
sind immer ein bisschen schwierig.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Zwei Tage vor Weihnachten.
Eigentlich war für heute
der Saisonstart geplant.
Zwar hatte man davor während ein paar
kalten Tagen beschneien können.
Doch dann hat es die Piste verregnet.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Darf man fragen, wo es hingeht?
Den Hügel hoch.
- Wir suchen den Schnee.
Dem Schnee hinterher nach oben.
- Wir gehen etwas hoch.
Das ist der Direktor.
- Ach, ja? - Hallo.
Eine kurze Frage:
Sie benutzen Tourenskis?
(Mann) Ja, genau.
- Das ist super.
Wir gehen etwas hoch.
- Das ist schön.
Das stellt das Gebiet
ja auch vor finanzielle Probleme.
Was würde das bedeuten, wenn
dieses Gebiet nicht überleben würde?
Ich weiss es nicht.
- Fürs Tal wäre es schade.
Auch für die Touristen.
Ja.
Finanziell
ist es hier halt auch noch ...
Es ist günstiger.
Wenn man sich die vier Grossen
im Oberland anschaut ...
Dort reisst Ski fahren
für eine vierköpfige Familie
ein ziemliches Loch
ins Portemonnaie.
Im Raum Thun ist es halt ...
Es ist nahe.
Ja, es ist familienfreundlich.
- Man kann es sich leisten.
Das Regenwetter -
es ist das alles beherrschende Thema.
Ja ...
Schade, dass die Saisoneröffnung
im Moment grün ist.
Definitiv. Hast du gesehen,
wie es uns den Schnee traktierte?
Aber ich weiss, wie es ist.
Abends ist die Piste top,
dann kommt das Wetter,
und am Morgen könnte man heulen.
Ja. Ich kam gerade vom Restaurant
Alp Schwarzenberg herunter:
total vereist.
- Und morgen wird es ja ...
Sie führen das Bergrestaurant?
Genau, wir haben es
den Winter über gemietet.
Ansonsten wohnen wir im Seeland.
Wir kommen aus Bargen bei Aarberg.
Nun haben wir es mal
für eine erste Saison gemietet.
Die erste Saison?
- Die allererste Saison, genau.
Und jetzt hoffe ich auf Schnee
und entsprechend viele Gäste.
Viele Leute
kennen das noch von früher.
Es gab viele,
die auf dem Wiriehorn Ski fuhren.
Ich tat das schon
mit meinem Vater in den 70er-Jahren.
Und was bedeutet das jetzt für Sie?
Ja, bis jetzt v.a. Ausgaben,
damit dieser Jumbo
irgendwann mal zu fliegen beginnt.
Aber wir sind
immer noch zuversichtlich.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Die Bahn ist für viele Menschen
im 2'000-Seelen-Tal wichtig.
Auch für Bauer Hansruedi Reber.
Wenn im Diemtigtal Schnee liegt,
arbeitet er in Teilzeit am Lift.
Wann begannen Sie,
für die Sesselbahn zu arbeiten?
Im Jahr 2007.
- Und wieso?
Ich fällte mit jemandem Holz,
der bei den Grimmialpbahnen
angestellt wurde.
Dann war es ein Zufall.
Mein Schwager arbeitete dort,
und sie waren zu wenige Leute.
Sie fragten mich,
ob ich mal probearbeiten wolle.
Seither bin ich dort.
Was gibt Ihnen diese Arbeit?
Abwechslung, damit ich nicht nur
den ganzen Tag Kühe und Holz sehe.
Ich rede auch gerne mit den Gästen,
zumindest wenn
sie sich anständig aufführen.
Das verschafft mir
Abwechslung zum Bauernalltag.
Und finanziell?
Finanziell
ist es ein Zusatzverdienst.
Im Winter läuft
in der Landwirtschaft nicht so viel.
Da kann man locker ...
Es sind auch günstige Arbeitszeiten:
von 9 Uhr bis 16, 16.30 Uhr.
Da kann ich morgens und abends
noch in den Stall.
Es ist nicht so wie auf dem Bau,
wo man um 7 Uhr anfängt
und um 18 Uhr aufhört.
Ja.
Aber finden Sie es richtig, dass
die Gemeinde die Bahn unterstützt?
Es hängt viel davon ab.
Das ist schon gut.
Die Frage ist,
wie lange das noch so geht.
Die jetzigen Generationen
hängen daran und finden das wichtig.
Ob zukünftige Generationen
gewillt sind,
das weiterhin zu unterstützen,
ist schwer zu sagen.
Aber zurzeit ist es sicher
richtig und gut, dass es getan wird.
Die letzte Finanzhilfe
über 150'000 Fr.
wurde an der Gemeindeversammlung
klar angenommen.
Bei 268 Anwesenden
gab es lediglich 16 Gegenstimmen.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Guten Tag.
Haben Sie heute zum ersten Mal
für die Skifahrer geöffnet?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Gestern hatten wir für Rodler
und Wanderer geöffnet.
Und wie ist die Gefühlslage?
Wunderbar, eigentlich.
Hier oben ist es grün,
bis ziemlich weit nach oben.
Dass wir die Talabfahrt öffnen
konnten, ist natürlich wunderbar.
Sind Sie zufrieden damit,
wie es läuft?
Ja, für den Betrieb,
den wir anbieten können,
sind einige Gäste hier.
Und das Ponyreiten und das Trampolin
sind keine Option mehr?
Das ist keine Option mehr. Jetzt
haben wir einen schönen Skibetrieb.
Oben haben wir ein Schlittel-
und Wanderangebot im Schnee.
Das passt sehr gut.
Die Skilifte oben
stehen allerdings noch still.
Zum Leidwesen der Pächter
des Bergrestaurants Schwarzenberg,
dem Ehepaar Martin und Andrea Bieri.
Immer noch guten Mutes?
- Ja, ja.
Für uns ist es
natürlich matchentscheidend,
ob der Lift eingeschaltet wird
oder nicht,
damit die Leute mit den Skiern
hierherfahren können.
Wird hier nicht beschneit?
- Doch, hier wird auch beschneit.
Aber die Talstation
hat natürlich erste Priorität,
damit sie runterfahren können.
Dort kann man auch nachts Ski fahren
und schlitteln.
Auf dieser Höhe ist es halt
immer eine Frage der Ressourcen.
Wie viel Geld kann man investieren?
Zweite Priorität hat der Kinderlift
und dritte Priorität
dieser Doppellift.
Daher wären wir froh, wenn sie die
zweite Piste auch beschneien würden.
Aber jetzt ist es
bereits wieder relativ warm,
viel wärmer als gestern.
Den ganzen Vormittag
lassen sich nur diese beiden blicken:
Freunde der Bieris,
die im Betrieb mithelfen.
Andrea Bieri und ihr Mann haben rund
25'000 Fr. für die Saison investiert.
Darum hoffen sie so sehr auf Schnee.
Wie viel fehlt noch?
Ich würde sagen,
etwa 30 cm fehlen schon.
Das wäre schon noch wichtig.
- Ja, es wäre wichtig für uns.
Zumindest dieser da.
Sonst kommen
die Skifahrer nicht hoch.
Aber jetzt hoffen wir auf Wanderer.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Nix war's. Der Tourenskifahrer
verpflegt sich selber.
Doch dann,
ausgerechnet beim Mittagessen,
endlich die ersten Gäste.
Guten Tag. Schön, dass Sie
den Weg hierher gefunden haben.
Wir dachten schon, heute käme
niemand - ausgerechnet heute.
Wir kamen extra von Bern hierher.
- Vorhin parkten noch einige.
Wir wollten ihr
ein bisschen Schnee zeigen. - Super.
Immerhin: Bis am Abend
werden es 741.50 Fr. Umsatz sein.
Bis sich die Investitionen decken,
ist es aber noch ein weiter Weg.
Nur fünf Festangestellte
arbeiten bei den Wiriehornbahnen.
Aber rund 50 Personen sind,
wie Bauer Hansruedi Reber,
im Teilzeitpensum angestellt.
Freuten Sie sich?
- Ja, es ist gut, dass es los geht.
Aber es sind noch nicht
alle im Einsatz, was?
Nein, nein, erst ganz wenige.
Einer bei der unteren Bahn,
einer hier oben
und ein paar Patrouilleure.
Und wieso wählte man Sie aus?
Nimmt man die Besten?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob nach Schönheit entschieden wird.
Nein, nein, das wird so eingeteilt.
Für mich ist danach
wohl Schluss für diese Woche.
Es wird immer schön abgewechselt.
Es hat niemand das Privileg,
arbeiten zu dürfen.
Und der Schnee? Was wurde gemeldet?
Ich bin gar nicht im Bilde,
was Petrus will.
Aber als Einheimischer
spürt man das doch?
Ich kann mich nicht
auf meine Gefühle verlassen.
Laut meinen Gefühlen
müsste viel Schnee liegen.
Trotz schwierigem Beginn:
Der Saisonstart ging doch noch
irgendwie über die Bühne.
Es hat in den letzten Jahren
schlechtere gegeben.
Einen Monat später.
* Ankündigungston für Durchsage *
(Durchsage) Diemtigen Dorf.
Es hat viel geschneit.
Alle Lifte laufen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Aber es gibt
beunruhigende Nachrichten.
Geschäftsführer Wiedmer war eine gute
Woche für fast niemanden erreichbar.
Er musste eine Auszeit nehmen,
hiess es.
So.
- Jetzt.
Wir fahren mit Andreas Wiedmer
zum Bergrestaurant Schwarzenberg,
zu den Bieris.
Er sagt uns,
er habe alle Managementämter
an den Verwaltungsrat abgegeben
und sei nur noch
für das Technische verantwortlich.
Das Schönste am Ganzen
war eigentlich,
als ich zu Hause
meine Kinder informierte.
Sie freuten sich total
über meinen Entscheid.
Die Kinder?
- Ja.
Sie freuten sich wirklich.
Ich hatte ein wenig Angst davor.
Sie waren extrem stolz darauf,
dass ich hier der Chef bin
und dass sie sagen konnten,
sie würden bei mir Ski fahren.
Sie nahmen das sehr gut auf
und begrüssten es sehr.
Können Sie
Res' Entscheidung nachvollziehen?
Ja, absolut. Wir sahen ja,
wie er Tag und Nacht arbeitete.
Abends half er beim Beschneien
und morgens
war er wieder als Erster hier.
Als die Saison
hätte eröffnet werden sollen,
war er auch da
und sprach mit den Leuten.
Mehr kann man nicht tun.
Uns half er auch immer.
Wenn wir ein Anliegen hatten ...
- Wir hatten auch Ansprüche.
Er war immer bereit.
Er sagte immer:
"Ruf an, wenn etwas ist, wenn du
nicht hoch oder runter kommst!"
"Dann helfe ich dir."
Solche Leute sind Gold wert
für ein solches Skigebiet,
aber für mich
ist es absolut verständlich,
dass man
irgendwann einfach genug hat.
Das ist schön, das zu hören.
Weisst du, wir wissen, dass ...
- Aber, ähm ...
Für mich
war es einfach wirklich wichtig ...
... die Prioritäten
anders zu setzen.
Weil ... Ja ...
Ich wäre so
wahrscheinlich nicht weitergekommen.
Ich hätte mich
nur noch rückwärts bewegt.
Mir geht es seit einer Woche anders.
Mir ist wirklich ganz anders zumute.
Besser zumute ...
... als vor einer Woche.
Pass auf dich auf.
- Tschüss, Andrea.
Macht's gut. Tschüss zusammen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ein Höhepunkt der Saison:
das grosse Familienskirennen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Der Schnee sollte am Wiriehorn
bis Saisonende reichen.
Aber es findet ein Umdenken statt.
Man will in Zukunft
vermehrt auf Sommertouristen setzen
und unabhängiger sein
vom Winterwetter.
Welche Lehren für die Zukunft
ziehen Sie daraus?
Wir wissen, dass das
eine Zitterpartei ist und bleibt.
Aber wir richten uns so aus, dass es
die Zitterpartie nicht geben sollte.
Wir versuchen,
im Sommer ein Polster zu schaffen,
damit wir im Winter
nicht zittern müssen,
falls es mal nicht schneien sollte.
Aber wir brauchen sicher
noch ein bis zwei
oder sogar drei bis vier Jahre,
bis das Sommergeschäft so weit ist.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Und das nächste Jahr?
War das eine einmalige Übung
oder wiederholen Sie es?
Das werden wir später entscheiden.
Jetzt beenden wir sicher
mal diese Saison und ziehen Bilanz.
Es muss nicht viel sein, aber etwas
sollte schon dabei rausschauen.
Wenn wir damit nur unsere Rechnungen
bezahlen können,
macht es schon nicht so viel Spass.
Daher schauen wir,
wie es bis Ende März aussieht.
Dann sehen wir,
ob wir es nochmals machen
oder ob es eine einmalige Übung war.
Falls dem so sein sollte, war es
auf jeden Fall eine schöne Übung.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Angestrengtes Stöhnen *
Jetzt ist halt Winter.
Ich glaube, viele Leute wissen
gar nicht mehr, was Winter ist.
* Lachen *
Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Uah!
Schönen Tag!
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Willst du mir einen Stock geben?
Beide? Nein, nicht ausziehen!